Buster is bringing his talents to
television now playing the patriarch of
a powerful family of ranchers who fight
to keep their land and legacy in
Yellowstone season 2 starts this week
how many times arrested on recording
with you Donnie
stood for you I think you'd be sheriff
if it weren't for me maybe you ever
noticed but there's a war going on in
this valley today's the day your two
sides kevin costner good morning welcome
thanks for being here this was your
first TV series and I read that you
thought initially it would just be one
season wrong so successful it's now in
its second yeah that's like I was raised
in like a cave or something keep going
or something like that yeah how do you
like working in TV it's it it's always a
long day it never that doesn't change
and I we don't we don't treat it like TV
we treat it like it wants to last
forever that's how we go about it and so
you know it doesn't change you know you
work on a low-budget movie you work on a
big-budget movie the days are always
going to be loud mm-hmm why was it
important for you to cover the struggles
of ranchers in the modern West
I didn't think but in that way I mean I
I try to put the audience on my shoulder
the first time I read this script
because you you go to the TV you go to
the movies for something you know the
lights go out you want to just be
transported and so when I read a script
all sudden I feel myself being
transported and suddenly we're in the
Bitterroot Valley the same Valley that
concept that Lewis and Clark went down
and people are reminded once again when
they watch that these places still exist
I you know we can you can get caught up
in what we do but you know
incredible amount of history went down
out there and I don't think we ever tire
seeing running rivers and valleys and
mountains and if you can set a drama
against all that it's fun I think we've
said a girl boy movie against minor
league baseball and Bull Durham it's fun
yeah yeah when you hear about actors
doing westerns you often hear a back
story usually humorous back story but
how to learn how to ride wasn't a
problem for you though you already rode
did you have to learn anything new yeah
no well there's a lot listen I I I'm
okay I'm okay right around people who
are really good with horses but it's
something I've wanted something I've
done since I was little wanted to do and
I think everybody and I think that's one
of the joys when you go to the movies
who wouldn't want to run with the
Buffalo mhm and I just don't like
necessarily giving that up to Scott man
I want to do as much as I can although
you know I have stuntmen were able to do
most of it
yeah pretty yeah most of it yeah exactly
that's that's yeah in certain instances
you just have to you know it's the fun
of doing movies who doesn't want to get
to kiss the girl save the day
you know climb the building and you know
turn off the bomb talking about your
pass and the great movies that we saw
highlighted before the bodyguard my
personal favorite I remember reading
that you said you didn't think it was
going to have the kind of power that it
ended up having at the time why not well
I think you know I think some people
talked about the the the interracial
thing and I didn't think anything about
that I just kind of went for the
prettiest girl that could sing they
could really ii really and so for me i
didn't realize i think what you're
talking about is later on that there was
a lot of power behind that that kind of
created oh i don't know what it did i
just instinctually went to what i
thought would make for the best movie
this year's the 30th anniversary of
Field of Dreams where one day after
Father's Day that is a father-son movie
if there ever was one
why do you think it's lasted so long I
don't know I feel like it's kind of our
generations wonderful life
and I understand it's actually in the
big theaters the next couple of days and
people are going taking their sons
taking it it's not just for men but it
has its it's crushed people in the very
first day broke their heart in two
thousand pieces it got little moving you
just have this little gold dust on it
and you know so much about relationships
with your father go unsaid and and you
got a you got to break that cycle or you
gonna need a Field of Dreams to remind
you of what you maybe missed perfect
sentiment after Father's Day Kevin
Costner thank you so much for joining us
at the table